alrighty today we are going to be
reviewing
a children's book by noted cult leader
and fascist
ibrahim x kendi i say that he's a cult
leader because he actually says things
like
if you don't listen to me and repeat
what i say then you are a racist and you
can only be cleansed of your racism by
paying me twenty thousand dollars to do
a diversity session about how you're
racist
and also i say he's a fascist because he
has literally proposed in writing
that there be a federal department of
anti-racism to strike down i kid you not
any law that has a disparate impact
meaning that if any group
does worse under a law than any other
group then the law can be struck down by
the department of anti-racism
which is called every single law ever in
the history of humanity because you can
draw a line down the middle of a room
without regard to race
age or anything and you will end up with
disparate impact on the people on either
side of the line
okay so the guy is just a charlatan he
is a fraud and he is
highly sought after for diversity
speaking initiatives at various
corporations seeking to avoid
liability okay so he wrote a children's
book like a book for kids so you can
indoctrinate small babies in this book
so it's called anti-racist baby looks
excellent
here we go okay so the book begins with
dedications
so ibrahim kendi writes like a nice
dedication presumably to his kid imani
and then the illustrator writes this to
all the young people whose own
imaginations are unbound by the
imaginations of state violence and white
supremacy
and the power we hold to build a world
that is anti-racist
i believe in us yes all your hope lies
in the ability of a small child who has
not yet been indoctrinated into the
institutions
of evil but who unfortunately has no
ability to wipe their own ass
anti-racist baby is bred not born
okay so how are we going to indoctrinate
your child today because your child is
going to be bred
babies are taught to be racist or
anti-racist there is no neutrality
um what if you're just not racist well
according to ibram candy
seriously he actually believes that if
you say that you're not racist and you
don't do anything racist
you're actually still racist because
you're not anti-racist anti-racist means
that you believe that every institution
that has a disparate impact needs to be
torn to the ground this is actual theory
so babies are taught to be racist or
anti-racist either you indoctrinate them
to believe what abram kennedy believes
or you are
right he eliminated one of those options
now if you don't do a number if you're
not anti-racist like abram kennedy that
means your baby's a racist
take these nine steps to make equity a
reality ooh i'm so excited
one open your eyes to all skin colors
anti-racist baby learns all the colors
not because race is true if you claim to
be colorblind you deny
what's right in front of you okay so um
that is so self-refuting i mean like
completely self-refuting
right he says that you have to learn
everybody's color
because race is not true but if phrase
is not true why would you bother to
learn everybody's color like who cares
right either you're a racial
essentialist in which case you should
know everybody's color because they're
racial differences that are essential
which is racist
or you should learn everybody's racial
color
for no reason he says if you claim to be
colorblind you deny what's right in
front of you no
what you deny is ibrahim kennedy's
premise which is that you are
in fact a racist unless ibrahim candy
says that you are otherwise deems you
otherwise
two use your words to talk about race no
one will see racism if we only stay
silent
if we don't name racism it won't stop
being so violent
yes what we need is two-year-olds
deeming things racist that sounds great
i mean as as a person with small
children what i need is my children
running around on the streets calling
things racist when they don't
literally learn how to wipe their own
asses makes perfect sense to me
also no one will see racism if we only
stay
silent i i'm i'm confused just because
i feel like we will still see
racism we just won't be speaking about
it now you want to make the case
that we should speak out against racism
that sounds good i'm all for it but the
problem is again he defines racism
as anything ibrahim kennedy doesn't like
okay three
point at policies as the problem not
people ah there we go there we go see
here you are now removing the definition
of racism you're teaching kids
that you don't actually have to be
racist in order to be racist right
instead of your kid you're teaching kids
they have to point out racism but
in order for them to point out racism
they don't have to spot a racist or
racist
intent all they have to do is find
something they don't like and call it
racist
he says some people get more while
others get less because policies
don't always grant equal access there is
a person who is catching butterflies in
the net
and one butterfly is not caught this
means that this person
is racist against this particular type
of butterfly
now we have no idea why this person is
catching that particular type of
butterfly maybe they need to do research
on that type
it's a butterfly by the way not a human
okay number one number two
maybe it's because those butterflies are
easier to catch and this person catches
butterflies for a living maybe the
person is evil and really really hates
blue butterflies we don't know
but we can simply assume that because
there is a disparity discrimination has
taken place this is what we are teaching
small children
because everything is incredibly stupid
four
shout there's nothing wrong with the
people even though all races are not
treated the same
we are all human anti-racist baby can
proclaim
so the point here right and the subtle
point here
is that what he has said and this is
what ibram candy has said in his writing
for adults
which is also written like it is for
children because the only idiots would
believe it
and children are basically small adults
who are idiots when he says there's
nothing wrong with the people what he
means is if there's any disparity in
outcome
you cannot attribute that to the
individual decisions of the people
or you have to attribute it to the
policies so if you have one person who
makes a bunch of bad decisions and ends
up impoverished
or somebody robs a bank and goes to jail
it's not because the person made a bad
decision to rob a bank and then ended up
in jail
there's nothing wrong with the person
you see it was the policies that drove
him to do that
right this is what we are supposed to be
teaching children which by the way is a
great message for kids
i think the best the best message for
kids who lack a sense of personal
responsibility in the first place and
are really selfish little creatures
kids are innocent but they are not good
anybody who's ever had a kid can tell
you this
right kids can be horrific kids can be
cruel to one another
kids can be violent and brutal if a four
year old had the body of a 40 year old
the world would be over
right four-year-olds just walk around
hitting each other and screaming
and pulling things down and wrecking
things kids are wonderful
i have three of them okay they're
wonderful they're the joys of my life
they're not good
they're innocent okay you have to teach
them to be good that's what civilization
is for
teaching a child that individual action
does not matter
right that there's nothing wrong with
the people what meaning there's nothing
wrong with your individual choice no
matter what your choice is it should
result in the same outcome
is it literally a way to bring up
sociopathic children
okay five celebrate all our differences
anti-racist baby doesn't see certain
groups as better or worse
anti-racist baby loves a world that's
truly diverse
okay so is he now claiming that we
should see people as individuals
no that's silly of course not what he
means
is that no matter what choices anybody
makes
we are not allowed to say choices are
better or worse it doesn't mean that we
should see
every individual without regard to skin
color we should see every individual
based on
content of character he originally
disowned that in principle number one as
you will recall
now what he's actually saying is that
individual choice literally
should never be discriminated against
okay now here's my deal
i do discriminate based on individual
choice not based on skin color not based
on immutable characteristic based on
individual choice
if you choose to eat nails that is a
worse choice
than not choosing to eat nails okay i
discriminate based on that choice
as would any sentient human being but he
is saying that you shouldn't do that
right you should
every every choice is equally good and
only cultural
only cultural racism is what causes you
to think that some choices are better
than others if some people choose to eat
nails
that's just a different culture right
six knock down the stack
of cultural blocks anti-racist baby
appreciates how groups speak
dance and create as they choose
anti-racist baby welcomes all groups
voicing
their unique views okay well i just have
a question
are there any limits on this behavior
right because you're supposed to knock
down the stack of cultural blocks which
means that presumably every cultural
behavior
is a manifestation of systems of power
are there any but they're no bad choices
right this is what we're learning here
anti-racist baby appreciates how groups
speak dance and create
how about what if that like burning down
cities what if they're like riots in the
streets what if people are hitting each
other with baseball bats like are we
supposed to appreciate that it's just
sort of a cultural difference
are we supposed to just think that if
you make bad decisions that's just
cultural difference
and it's not a matter of unique
viewpoint right unless he
includes a non-harm principle here this
is a bad principle
seven confess when being ready ah
confess confess baby
small baby confess your sins teach your
two-year-old
to confess to being racist okay i have a
four-year-old
i can't even get my four-year-old to
confess that he drew on the counter with
a sharpie
okay are you kidding me yeah you're for
confess anybody who actually teaches
this crap to their kids should be
brought up on charges of child abuse
seriously
seven confess when being racist nothing
disrupts racism more than when we
confess the racist ideas we sometimes
express
okay but again he's defining racist as
anything he doesn't like
so this is where the cult leader part
comes in he gets to determine if
something is racist
if you refuse to confess your racism
along those lines
this is because you are a racist and you
must confess confess
and give ibram kennedy 20 000 for a
diversity training session
eight grow to be an anti-racist
anti-racist baby is always learning
changing and growing
anti-racist baby stays curious about all
people and isn't
all-knowing well unless anti-racist baby
grows up to be abram kenny then he knows
everything
and he gets to change the standards just
willy-nilly at random depending on what
he deems racist
that day what a wonderful book what a
wonderful one
nine believe we shall overcome racism
but wait a second i've been told that we
can never overcome racism seriously
there's no ability to overcome racism
you can never fully do the work is what
abram kennedy says
we can only pursue the utopian goal
there's no point where utopia actually
manifests
it doesn't happen because after all we
have to continue seeing each other as
groups
and we have to create laws in which the
outcome is the same for everybody
which is never going to happen ever so
you actually can never overcome racism
because again
he defines racism as whatever he doesn't
i assume abram kenny will always have
things he doesn't like
so the definition will continue changing
forever but believe we can overcome
anti-racist baby is filled with the
power to transcend my friend
and doesn't judge a book by its cover
but reads until
the end oh we did we got through it guys
we got through it together
what a beautiful bunch of absolutely
garbage horse for children okay we'll
get some more of this in just one
second but first i need to tell you
about something incredible something
unbelievable something
raycon raycon is great
i know raycon is great because i'm
holding it here in my hand and the
everyday e25 earbuds these are the best
ones yet we're talking seamless
bluetooth pairing we're talking six
hours of play time
we are talking about excellent quality
that rivals any of the others on the
market and it's gonna cost you like half
of what other wireless earbuds are going
to cost you so why aren't you checking
them out
right now raycon offers their wireless
earbuds in a range of fun colors and
patterns
they are super comfortable they fit your
ear perfectly you can actually customize
them to fit your ear
exactly how you want them to fit so they
are not just one size fits all
the compact carrying case it can charge
your earbuds four times on a single
charge and unlike some of those other
wireless options
earbuds are both stylish and discreet no
dangling wires no stems they are great
for video chats so go check out raycons
right now they start about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market
they sound just as good great for
working from home working out listening
to music and podcasts for hours without
driving your roommates or significant
other children or neighbors crazy
go check them out right now click the
link in the description below let's get
15 off your order
and click that link in the description
below 15 off your recons
[Music]
oh my god yeah this is yeah this is
learning time
dear parents and caregivers it is
critical we begin explicit conversations
about race and racism with our children
from a young age
just as we teach our kids to be kind
even before they fully understand what
it means to be kind
we should teach our kids to be
anti-racist even before they fully
understand what it means
to be anti-racist those are not the same
thing
teaching can be kind means not hitting
other kids means being kind of nice
teaching kid to be anti-racist means
that you have to indoctrinate them that
all institutions in society are suffused
with white supremacy and exploitation
i feel like that concept not only is it
but it's kind of hard to convey to a
two-year-old
ask your child to describe the people in
their friend group and yours it is a
fallacy that children are colorblind
help your child explicitly name the race
of the people around them so they
understand it is not insulting or
harmful to do so
we want to normalize discussions about
race and remove the stigma around these
conversations
okay now i honestly don't have a problem
with with my kids saying there's a black
guy who cares and
that's true it is important for children
to name the race of the people around
them so you can ask them what they think
about those different races
why they think those things and instruct
them on how to understand racial
difference
as an imagined construct but one with
very real consequences
you want to teach them this you don't
want to assume children are a blank
slate this leaves room for racist
societal messages to shape their
understanding of racism
instead okay what if i don't feel like
grilling my kid on what they think of
various races because kids are dumb what
if instead
i just say right there's a black guy
right there's a latino guy
right there's a lady like what's the
problem
with dad and then if my kid ever
expressed something like are women
allowed to be x y or z you say of course
women are allowed to be
x y or z like that's just normal
parenting but the idea is you're
supposed to grill your kid for their
racist internals and then you're
supposed to re-educate them like right
away
help children understand that racist
policies are pr are the problem not
people out here here's where we really
go
you and your child can reflect on the
racial makeup of your school or
neighborhood are they truly diverse
or do you live in a neighborhood or
attend a school that is segregated help
children understand that this is a
result of racist policy
and talk about how this affects which
schools may receive more resources
over others okay so i'm supposed to take
my six-year-old to school
and be like oh that's because the
administrators are racist and
historically there is redlining in the
neighborhood
or i could you know assume that the kid
is six
like it's fine to talk about all this
stuff i'm just wondering why it's
necessary to do with a four-year-old
challenge the idea that all people are
treated the same it is common to share
lessons like be kind to everyone with
kids but this reinforces the idea that
racist acts are only carried out on an
individual level that ignores that all
people are not given the same access to
necessary resources
okay so why should i not i'm confused i
shouldn't be telling my kids to be kind
to everybody
should i be telling my kid to be an ass
to everybody i guess i could
but i feel like that makes the world
worse says although we might teach kids
anyone can do anything
we also have to teach them that racist
barriers exist that stop us all from
being truly free
understanding this is the first step in
helping to change it being kind does not
mean that we avoid seeing race but that
we celebrate racial differences
okay that is a completely disjointed
statement from the rest of that
paragraph
but the idea that i can't teach my kid
that anybody can do anything because i
have to teach them
that if they're a girl if i teach my
oldest daughter
actually there are structural barriers
to your success what do you think that
teaches kids what you're actually
teaching kids is not to try
that's what you're teaching kids the
reality is that in america it's a free
country
for the most part anybody can do
anything that does not mean
that there are not barriers in
everybody's life it does mean that we
should work to alleviate those barriers
but
i'm not supposed to teach kids that i'm
supposed to teach them the importance of
the barriers but not the importance of
individual choice this is bad parenting
remember to talk to your kids about how
people aren't just racist or anti-racist
but rather how their actions can be
racist or anti-racist ah so again
once more it is not people that are the
problem it is merely the actions that
are put upon them by society
kids might understand how this is
similar is when we say we don't consider
them to be a bad kid
when they do something wrong but we must
acknowledge that they make a bad choice
they have the opportunity to make a
better choice the next time because we
know that identity is not fixed
being anti-racist is about what we do
not who we are but hold up i was told
that individual choice doesn't matter
seriously he's now saying that you can
make the choice to be racist or
anti-racist but i was told that i'm not
allowed to blame people for their
choices or to credit people for their
choices society made me the way i am so
shut up abram candy
right seriously society shaped all of
the forces around me i'm not responsible
for my own decisions
except apparently i am i get to decide
whether to pay abram county 20 grand a
pop
so good stuff right there thank you
everyone kenny for this educational tour
through stupidity
that was just that was wonderful i'm so
glad that we read anti-racist baby
by ibram kendi if you read this to a
child your child is seven times stupider
and 23
000 times a worse person than if they
never read this book
hey you should not read this book this
is a terrible book
i've explained to you step by step why
this is a terrible book
that was how to be an anti-racist baby
by cult leader ibram kennedy
i hope you enjoyed it as little as i did
well thanks for tuning in hope you
enjoyed that if you want me to review
any other
masterful works of art from the
political left let me know in the
comments below